A very warm welcome to everyone
at Microsoft Research for
the second workshop which is
on issues of AI and society.
We've had a first workshop
in the past and part
of the afternoon will be
recapping what happened
the first time around.
The major change
from the first time
was that when we did
it the first time,
it was primarily people
who are academics,
and research and practice,
who were part of the workshop.
The one thing we did
realize is that it makes
a big difference to do
this with people who are
actively in the social sector.
As you've all probably realized,
AI and society is
quite the buzzword these days.
Even Resnick Anns latest film
is about artificial intelligence.
So, this is not just one
more event in that space.
What we are trying to do is
aggressively engage with
problems which are coming
from the social sector and look
at how technologies
can partner with that.
So, the format of the day
is that the first half,
which is Talkspace, is we'll
start off with the talk
from the center director
and from the USC folks.
USC is the driver with
MSR of this event.
The second half of the day,
we'll have non-profits and
NGOs talking about some of
their problems that they'd like
to apply various data
related solutions to.
Following which, there will be
breakout sessions in which
people will actually get
together in groups
and talk about what
technology can do to solve
some of those problems.
So, in another sense,
the second part of
the workshop is
essentially a working workshop.
So, if you want to
sneak away before that,
the time is right after lunch.
So, having said that,
I'm going to go ahead and let
Sriram take it from here,
the Director of MSR India and
will introduce us to them, Raj.
>> Thank you so much, Jogi.
I want to thank all
colleagues from USC
for making this trip all the
way here and doing
this workshop together with us.
I'm also very excited to
welcome all the NGOs and
people from the social sector.
As Jogi mentioned, we
had a previous event,
but that one was mostly
academic in nature.
I think I really want
to welcome all of you
for taking the time
to come here and participate in
this conversation with all of us.
This is a picture
of our first floor,
if you haven't seen it
you should go upstairs.
Absolutely beautiful office
we are blessed to have.
I invite you to go upstairs
and check, our gig out.
So, the subject of my talk is
to give some context
for who we are,
and why we're doing
this. That's my goal.
So, that you have a sense for
why we're doing what we're doing.
To that end I shared, I wanted to
first introduce
Microsoft Research.
Microsoft Research was set up
in 1991 and we are
a global organization.
We have four labs in
the United States,
one in the West Coast, and
three in the East Coast,
we have one in UK,
one here in Bangalore,
and one in China in Beijing.
We are more than a
thousand people;
850 PhDs,
which Rick Rashid computes it
as n Computer
Science departments.
I guess it is 850 divided by
50, whatever that number is.
That many Computer Science
departments, and engineers,
and development horsepower,
to take those ideas actually
and transition them.
This is our mission and
I think Rick Rashid was
a big Star Trek fan.
So, I think this mission is
somewhat modeled around I
guess this is to explore
new worlds, civilizations.
I think the last one is
to boldly go nowhere
no man has gone
before and whatever.
So, you can see.
But it's interesting and
inspiring that the mission is
written in such a way that it
doesn't talk about
Microsoft's current products.
It gives us Microsoft Research,
the ability to have as
its first and foremost goal,
to expand the state
of the art which
really drives the culture
of this organization.
This is us, this is
Microsoft Research India.
We were set up in 2005,
so we just became a teenager.
I think we are now 13 years old
and this is all of us.
You can fit us all
in one picture.
I always like to brag
about my colleagues.
So, these are awards
that my colleagues
have won recently.
Bill, this was
a year before last,
he won the McCarthy prize.
We had three ACM
Fellows recently.
Venkat also won the Shanti
Swarup Bhatnagar Prize,
which is one of
the highest awards
that the Indian government
offers to scientific research.
It is the first time
they've given it to
someone who's not in
an IAD or a DRDO or
government organization.
They gave it to someone working
in a multinational Lab,
which is a real testament to
how people value and
respect what we do.
Indrani recently won
the SGCHi Social Impact Award.
That's the sense for the
colleagues that we have.
This is our younger crowd
in addition to
the full-time people.
We have a program called
Research Fellow Program where
we recruit undergraduates,
people who have
finished bachelor's and
master's and we recruit
them as research trainees.
They spend one to
two years with us.
We currently have
40 Research Fellows,
I think we run the risk of
them exceeding the number
of full-time employees
I think sometime soon.
We actually started with
five Research Fellows,
now we have 40.
For those 40 positions,
we get more than a
thousand applications.
The best from all the IADs,
and BITS Pilani's,
and the TUPLETE's apply there
and they bring so much energy,
much like students
bring in academia.
We have 40 of them
currently here.
So, one thing that happens
is that a lot of them go
do PhDs after they
finish their time here.
They could apply to
UCS, or in Berkeley,
they go to US universities,
European universities, but some
of them decide not
to do research.
The ones that decide not to do
research tend to do better.
So, Ola was started
by one of them.
By any measure of imagination,
I think he's doing well.
Capillary was started
by Krishna Mehra,
who was an Arif with me and
these are other companies
that were started out of
staff that led in the lab.
That gives you a sense for how
entrepreneurial the lab is.
The large measure it is
due to the young people,
the new talent that
we get every year.
This describes the work
that we do in this lab,
our work is organized
on four major areas.
We do a lot of work in theory
and foundations of
computer science,
mathematics behind
machine learning,
we have a very strong group
that does core
or machine learning and
artificial intelligence,
algorithms, tools,
implementations, natural
language processing.
So, we are very well represented
in those areas as well.
We have a very strong
group and systems
which is the foundations
and infrastructure,
based on which
everything is built.
There is a very unique
group in this lab
called technologies
are emerging markets,
which studies the role
of technology in
socioeconomic development and it
is most relevant to
today's meeting.
This is an interdisciplinary
group that
contains both computer
scientists as well as
social scientists and
a lot of the work that I
will talk about today
is from this group.
But increasingly, the area
of technology for societal
good is becoming very
interdisciplinary and
people with background in
systems and machine learning are
also doing work in these areas.
So, I would broadly
represent work
from the entire lab in this area.
So, actually, I also wanted
to mention that as a lab,
we think about our work having
impact along three axis,
one is in science
advancing the state of art
in anything and everything
that we do, the second
one is company.
There's a lot of stuff that we do
that gets transitioned into
either existing products or
inspires new products and
services for our company.
We explicitly acknowledge
in helping society
as an important part of the axis
of impact that we have.
So, for the people
that are here from
NGOs and social enterprises,
one thing that I should make very
clear is that the work that
we do in this space
is not CSR activity.
Our company has a CSR activity.
Then, there is a law in
India that two percent
of every company's revenue
is given and we do that too,
but this workshop
is not about that.
This workshop is about us
engaging as Scientists and
Technologists with you,
to help you solve problems
in collaboration with us.
That's what this
workshop is about.
The other interesting thing
that has happened is that
I joined MSR about 19 years ago,
and when I joined MSR,
Microsoft was a Windows
and Office company.
So, a lot of the
work that we did in
impacting society was largely
of no relevance to the company.
It was not relevant to
the company's products,
but if I now look at
our cloud and AI offerings,
is very integral to what
our accompany does.
We do want to engage
with government,
we want to engage with
large communities,
people understand what problems
they want to solve.
So, it's very much something that
our company commercially is
actually interested in as well.
You'll see examples of that
in the slides that
I'll show you next.
So, here I have some examples
of the kinds of things
that this lab has
done in the past.
So, I will start with
mature projects,
projects that have
had the benefit
of time and see where
they have gone now.
The first one on the far
left is a project called
IVR Junction that was
started by Will Thies.
This is a interactive
voice response system
so that people
in remote and communities
where people have
access to a feature phone
but perhaps don't
have the literacy skills
or they don't have
a smart phone to
engage on social media
like Facebook or
LinkedIn or Twitter.
But nevertheless, I think they
have very interesting
things to say,
they have issues like most of us.
Just like we get
upset when we get
a defective product and
we can flame on Facebook,
they would like to do
the same thing as well.
So, IVR Junction was a piece of
infrastructure that was developed
by Bill and his colleagues,
and then it was adopted
first by CGNet-Swara,
which is an NGO that
works in Gondwana
and several other
NGOs in the world,
even I know that Somali land
has actually adopted it.
You could go to the IVR
Junction web page and you will
see a huge list of
customers that are using
it to have these people
raise their issues,
schools where teachers
have not been paid,
their grievance has
been addressed.
There was a case of
a hospital which was only on
paper but there was
actually no hospital at
all. So, that has
been discovered.
So, it's very powerful and
empowering to people who
didn't have a voice before.
MEC is an online
learning experiment
that we did in this lab.
Which is we actually study
something called
blended learning,
where we combine online learning
together with
in-classroom education.
That was actually picked up by
our development center
in Hyderabad.
It has now evolved
into Project Sangam,
where the online learning system
is also being integrated
with LinkedIn,
and it is being offered as
a service for skilling and
job training for
low income labor.
So, it's very interesting.
Something that we didn't
anticipate that would
happen when we originally
started this project.
Digital Green is a video
enabled agricultural
extension which
was started as a project in
his lab and now it runs
in tens of thousands of
villages both in
India and in Africa.
99DOTS, and I think Emmy is here,
so she will give an update
on 99DOTS later.
It's an innovative
mHealth platform
for tuberculosis
medication adherence.
This is a project that
was started here,
and now we expanded off into
a startup called Everwell,
Andrew Cross is the CEO of
Everwell and it's
right down the street.
So, I think if you have
time, you could go
visit Everwell as well.
So, I wanted to give
you a sense for
the current projects that
are going on in this lab,
and my objective behind
doing this is so that you
get a sense for the kind of
problems that our staff
is interested in.
Because the goal of
this workshop is to
open collaborative
conversations between
our staff and all of you.
So, I hope that these things
give you the sense
for the kind of things that
our staff was interested in.
So, let me go from left to right.
So, the current work in the lab,
there is a lot of
interest in work.
So, Karya for example,
is a project where we are
targeting Mechanical Turk like
crowd-work for digital labor,
for transcription,
for labeling text,
for labeling date of speech,
so that automated
NLP can actually
be enabled for languages for
which we don't have
any training data.
We are working with
government to see
if the people who this crowd
work can actually be paid.
In a lot of cases, the government
is actually willing to
pay for such work.
So, Karya is such a project.
Avatar is very interesting,
it actually uses again,
crowd work to do verification.
Say you are an NGO and
you have donated money,
and somebody has built a toilet.
How do you know that the toilet
has been actually built?
So, this one uses
crowd sourcing to have
someone go there
stream a video and
then verify that a toilet
has been built and
we could pay and make
small micro payment and we
could do this verification
any number of
times so that if there's
something wrong,
we will come to know
about it, right?
So, that's another one.
Kaizala is a very
interesting platform that is
actually being built by
our development center.
It is a little bit like
WhatsApp but for enterprise.
So, it has a WhatsApp
like interface,
a chat interface for
the client but it also
has a server-side.
Where you can now
write server code
to manage all the
information and so on.
It has enterprise component of
chat as well and Jackie O'Neill
has been working
with that group to understand
the social implications of
how such a product
gets used by people.
The customers for
this turns out to be
Andhra Pradesh government SERP,
which turns out to be Society
for Elimination of Rural Poverty.
So, the customers of
something like this
turn out to be
field workers who do
society work and we
engage with them to
understand both technical
and non-technical aspects
of how such a product
should be built.
BlendNet is another very
interesting project
where we are trying to
use peer to peer connectivity
to transfer bulk data
between mobiles.
So, thanks to Reliance Jio,
2G, 3G connectivity is
very prevalent in India.
But it is still very hard
to download or upload
bulk media like video is
actually always hard to do.
So, BlendNet uses peer
to peer connectivity
for bulk data but still
uses Azure as
a network in order to
make sure that you can do peer to
peer without knowing
the other person.
So, you don't have to know who
the other person is
to get the video.
Azure knows who has
what video and it'll actually
stands for that for you.
Learn2Earn is
a very interesting system
where it uses micro-payments and
incentives for people to
learn information and
transmit it to others.
So, it is actually a platform for
widely spreading
information dissemination.
There's more, I'm not
going go through more
of these and we already
mentioned 99DOTS,
we have Amit Sharma
who is working
on technology for
mental health issues.
This is for financial inclusion.
We have a lot of work
that is going on
around technology
for accessibility.
That's a core area
of the lab now.
I want to show you a few more.
Natural language processing is
also very important area
in this lab.
Since this workshop is
about AI and societal good,
I should call out
specifically that NLP has
a huge promise for
bringing people
who have very low
textual literacy
and make the benefits
of digital technology
accessible to this population,
which is a huge
population in India.
AI, I think has a huge amount of
promise in inclusion for
serving these communities,
but there are significant
technical challenges because of
simply the absence of
annotated data for lots
and lots of these kinds
of languages.
So, that's actually a topic
that we actively work on.
Also I see Caliga and [inaudible]
back in the audience,
they study low-resource languages
and they have an active
engagement going on with
CGNet-Swara to make an AI
and NLP work for Gondi,
which is a tribal language with
absolutely no annotations today.
IoT is another area
where we do a lot of
work and we have work
in Internet of Things,
sensors for agriculture,
for safety.
How do you use
sensors to make sure
that we can monitor drivers and
help them have safe driving
behavior and so on.
If you're here you
might actually also
get a demo of
an interactive game.
I think Shir upstairs
can give you a demo.
These projects are projects where
we are using blockchain,
those kinds of technologies for
decentralized identity for making
sure that there is trust and
transparency in what people do.
Many of the NGOs
might be interested
in technologies that can ensure
that you can actually track
where your funds are
going and so on.
So, we have technologies
that are based on blockchain
to do those kinds of activities.
Hopefully, this gives
you a sense for the kind
of work that this lab does.
Please keep this in mind,
because I'm not saying
actually we will engage
with you only on these topics but
hopefully this gives you a sense
for where people are coming from.
Okay? So, I wanted to
show this slide as
a meta slide of what we have
learned over the years
doing all these projects.
Be it health, be it
education, and so on.
So, one of the things
about this lab is that
I would say in addition
to writing papers,
we actually deploy
what we've built here.
In fact actually, we write
a paper when we have
something to say,
and a paper is usually
a byproduct of what we do
rather than something that we do
because there's
a conference deadline.
I mentioned this not to
disparage economics but to
reflect on my own experience
as a student, right?
Because as a student, you have
to do that because that's
only way you can graduate,
and as faculty
then, we have to do
that because we are
the graduate students.
So, don't take me wrong.
So, I understand that.
But in the lab like this, we have
the luxury of doing deployments,
learning from them,
and only writing when we
have something to say.
So, one other thing that
we have learned is,
as a result of deployments
in several underserved
communities,
low resource environments,
how important people
are in the socio-technical
system that you are designing?
Where technology,
we repeatedly see,
takes root only if it is
an amplifier and it
amplifies people.
That those are
the only situations
where technology gets adopted.
When we see this time and again,
we see time again when work
with people with low literacy,
when we work with people
who are Uber drivers,
Ola drivers understanding
where they are coming from,
it's such an important part
of what we do.
So, we have ethnographers
and so on who just
immerse themselves
with these communities
and study what they do,
even before we even decide
what to do a project.
So, that's very much in
the culture of the lab.
Actually, another thing that
I'm very proud about is
the amount of effort that
goes into measurement
and evaluation.
Doing things like
randomized controlled trials
are now increasingly
using machine learning to
identify causal
effects and so on.
But we do write papers,
and a lot of our work
is also known in
the academic community for
papers that we've written.
I want to give an example of,
I showed you Indrani's
societal impact award.
That came because of
about 10 years of work
that she did thinking
about interface design for
low-literate communities.
So, that really
presented also a body of
work that is identified
with that research.
So Kentaro Toyama, who
started the TM group,
he also formed
this conference called ICTD,
which was the first avenue for
publication of
scholarly work in the space.
Now, ICTD has its 10th edition.
It's going to happen in
Ahmedabad next year.
There are other
conferences like Dev,
and I think the more recent one
and I think that
Willy and others have
been also involved in,
Joyojeet is involved in it,
I think Pilthi is involved in.
So, this lab has had
a significant role in getting
these community started.
We actively publish in these
communities as well, right?
I want to mention
quickly some other things that
we're doing more recently.
We recently started an effort
around a societal
impact incubator.
The reason why we did this was
to reflect our experiences,
doing projects like 99DOTS,
which transitioned into Everwell.
Digital Green which
transitioned into an NGO.
So, we have learned
that it's a journey,
and each journey is different
in each one of these projects.
To take something
that we cook up in
a lab and take it
to the community,
and not only take the community,
make it self-sustaining and
survive outside the lab, right?
And have an ecosystem
where there's funding,
there's a business model,
and there's people that
will take the idea on,
and the idea just
survives outside the lab.
We increasingly realize how
important that aspect of
the research that we do is.
So, we decided that
we wanted to bring
in- so, we did this call.
I'll show you the call
in the next page.
Where we wanted to bring in
partners, be it government,
be it social entrepreneurs,
to work with us to
participate in that part
of the journey.
One of the reasons why we did
this was actually we also
realized that there are
other parts of Microsoft,
other than Microsoft Research,
that are very interested
in this activity.
So, we are partnering
with them to
do this kind of
societal impact incubator.
That's the web page.
We had a call for
collaborative projects on
Cloud and AI technology
for societal impact.
These were the themes
that we put out.
Interestingly, if you see,
these themes align with
the projects that I
mentioned to you,
which is the work that
the people in the lab are doing.
So, we put this out.
We thought what's going to
happen and we received I think,
I don't know what
the right number is, 150? One?
>> 175.
>> Yes. We thought
maybe we'll get
50 submissions. We got 175.
I think now we got to go through
the process of evaluating them.
We are going to select like four
or five or something like that.
We are going to fund them,
and every one of them is going to
have somebody in the lab
to work with them.
That's actually in
some sense more
important than the funding
itself that we give.
We sort of think about this as
the process of connecting
with the community,
which is so important
for these projects,
for them to survive
outside the lab, right?
Actually that brings into
point about why we're
doing this workshop.
The reason why we do
calls like this and
this workshop is
because we are humble.
We realize that we cannot
do these things alone.
The community is such an
important part of what we do.
That is something that
we've learned over
the years and that's the reason
why we invite all of you.
The final topic I'll touch upon
is social implications of AI.
This is not true just for AI,
every time you have new
technology, could be automation,
could be nuclear power,
technology can cut both ways.
It can do good, it can do harm.
Any discussion about technology,
and particularly I think AI,
has to actually consider
social ethical implications
of what we're doing.
So, Jackie O'Neill
pointed this page to me.
This is a very interesting report
that if you haven't read
I encourage reading it.
It's a institute in
NYU called AINOW.
They have a report that
is AINOW 2016 report
and there's also
an AINOW 2017 report.
It brings out issues
about labor and
automation and potential job loss
from AI. How to think about that?
How to think about
bias and inclusion?
Which is fairness,
which is very important
when we use training data
to train machine
learning algorithms.
Whether we are training them
with a representative data
set that represents all of
us rather than omit
certain segments
of the population,
rights, and liberties.
Particularly about the
use of AI technology
by government around surveillance
and video surveillance,
facial recognition,
issues like that,
and more broadly around
issues around ethics
and governance.
I think that's such an
important topic to discuss.
I hope that when you have
your breakout sessions in
addition to discussing
technology,
I hope that we will also discuss
these topics integrally
of part of what we we do.
Interestingly, we have
inside Microsoft,
my manager, his name
is Eric Horvitz.
He is a big proponent of
careful consideration of
AI and ethics in society.
He has formed a committee
called the Aether Committee,
which stands for AI,
Ethics and Effects in
Engineering and Research.
These are the subcommittees,
there are seven
working groups that
are actively working inside
Microsoft Research and Microsoft,
around all these various
topics ranging from
sensitive uses,
bias and fairness.
Interestingly,
there's a coverage of
these seven topics
among the five things
that you saw in the AINOW report.
For example, I think AJ
Kumar, that Willy knows,
I think she's a co-head
of the Group on bias and
fairness for example.
So, we have resources
even inside Microsoft
to bring to bare on
these kinds of conversations,
and I encourage all of
you to make use of all of
these resources in
this conversation.
So, I'm almost about to end.
I wanted to introduce you
the multidisciplinary
team we have.
I realize Muthahan I have
forgotten your picture.
Sorry about that. So, I
wanted to show this because,
so we have social scientists,
we have computer scientists,
we have developers,
we have program managers,
we have a really diverse team
that works in this area.
These are research
fellows who are
students who are
spending time with us.
I think most of them
are here in this room,
and I think over time,
I think you will have
the opportunity to
interact with most of them.
This is the schedule for today.
I welcome my colleagues from
USC and all of you from
NGOs and social sector.
There is going to be
talks by several people.
As Joyojeet mentioned,
this is the second workshop
we are organizing.
There was one that we
did last year at ISC.
One of the things
that we're doing
this afternoon is to have
breakout sessions
where you engage with
our staff to really think about
what concrete ideas we
might work on together.
So, that's actually
very important
outcome of this workshop.
It's to actually really
catalyze concrete ideas
for collaboration.
And we did this last time,
and there're going to be updates
for some of the workshop.
Some of the projects I
think have made progress.
Ganesh is here already.
Ganesh Amageshi.
Yes, he is here. So, he was there
the last one and
this was discussed.
I think Ganesh and
colleagues have made a lot
of progress on that project.
So, they're going
to talk about that.
There's going to be also
an update on 99DOTS.
So, I am really
looking forward to
hearing from all of
you on the problems
that you're inspired by so
that we can collaborate.
So, the afternoon there's
going to be breakout sessions
where more problems are
going to be discussed.
There's people from
the government
that are giving talks
this afternoon.
Then there's going to be
presentations for
the breakout sessions,
and as you're thinking about it
you'll get to give talks on that.
I think that's pretty
much it. Okay. Thank you.
With that, we welcome
colleagues from
USC to give the next talk.
Yes. Thank you.